So I'm just going to start out by
giving you a quick overview of
the main steps that you need to do
to enable Analytics to give you useful
information about your Android app.
The first thing you're going to
need is an Analytics Account ID.
And you get that in
the Analytics dashboard UI.
And I'll be showing you how to do that.
Once you know your Analytics Account ID,
you need to add code to your app so
that your app knows to send
the data to Analytics.
The code's not very difficult, and
we'll be walking through that.
And once your app's started sending
data to Analytics, of course,
then you can use the Analytics dashboard
to look at all the awesome data.